oui l'opération a dû être reportée
quatre fois parce qu'il n'y avait pas
assez de personnel pour pratiquer
l'intervention sur le fémur de Claudette
Simon 77 ans c'est ce que nous explique
le chef de service de chirurgie
orthopédique du CHU c'est un
intervention n'a pas pu être réalisé
dans les délais souhaités du fait de
repos intempestif
successifs
intempestifs successifs sont dus
au défauts d'offres de vacations
au service des urgences au bloc des
urgences en effet vous savez que pour
que les salles soient ouvertes il faut
du personnel qualifié compétent pour
pouvoir opérer en toute sécurité des
reports qui ont conduit à la dégradation
de l'état de santé général de la
patiente elle souffrait de plusieurs
comorbidités en revanche elle a bien été
alimentée chaque jour la direction est
formelle sur ce point la mise à jeun
n'est pas sur une durée
de 24 heures c'est une période limitée
préalable à une probable intervention
chirurgicale et dès qu'il est
su que l'intervention chirurgicale n'a
pas lieu on revient sur un rythme
d'alimentation de la patiente raison
pour laquelle les repas sont commandés
alors à ce stade on ne sait pas
exactement ce qui a causé la mort de
Claudette Simon les résultats de son
autopsie ne sont pas encore arrivés en
tout cas la direction assure qu'elle
comprend les interrogations légitimes de
sa famille une enquête interne à
l'hôpital a justement été ouverte dès le
mois de septembre et l'Agence régionale
de santé on a été informé dans la foulée